yeah probably footballers boxers um i
get a lot of rappers in my dms i do want
a dm from giancarlo but i haven't had
that yet so
yeah jack if you're watching this
i will just say
[Music]
did you always want to be a youtuber
no that came to me later i wanted to be
a surgeon
so i was studying like medical science
like forensic science and that sort of
thing
um and then i dropped out of that
we went so when did you start youtube
channel um i started youtube when i was
17.
so i was in college and one of my
friends at the time
um had a lot of experience with like
instagram back then
and he's actually my manager now and
everyone knows him as my manager he's
called manager jay
but he was the one who said to me like
if you do want to make something of this
that i will help you along the way and
he knew like the right paths to do you
need the right strategies with youtube
that kind of thing like even back then
and yeah he he helped me the whole time
so i had good people around me helping
me out my mum was supportive when i
turned like 18
but yeah even my brother and sister were
like
yeah like that's
weird like why are you doing that and
what kind of content were you making in
the story um it was like
the more basic videos so
i would have videos like um
50 things about me and like stuff like
that it was the really like
youtube video ideas thing you'd find on
google and you'd be like what video
should i post on youtube so i started
doing that anyway guys on tv questions
on instagram because
that's what we're here for
would i fight rather fight one
horse-sized duck or 100 duck sized
horses
the duck-sized horses would be well cute
but ducks can actually be quite big so
probably like the giant duck
and then i started doing um i did a few
reaction videos but more
not just like sitting there and watching
something it'd be like really breaking
it down and kind of um
it would like just be given my opinion
on like youtube drama that kind of thing
i started doing more challenge videos
um i did some like prank videos that
sort of thing and then
um i got some companies send me like
clothes for
trial hauls and stuff so i started doing
trial hauls and then yeah now we have my
channel now as it is if on a youtube
video i asked like i asked people on
instagram like oh send me some questions
or send me some challenges to do
the things people send me are very very
very very very sexual and
they sent me stuff that i should be
doing on pornhub so obviously that's
stuff i'm not going to do on youtube
like that's just a no-go
what's the most common question that
people ask you my body count
everyone's just like what's your body
count or like have you slept with any
other youtubers and i'm like
no
but a lot of the time people are also
asking for advice so people will be like
um
oh i really like this one person
i don't think she's into me how like how
do i make a girl like me that sort of
thing i get that a lot every single
video i do i talk to them about consent
i talk about
um
[Music]
not letting people pressure you into
doing things that sort of thing for
example i'll talk about a certain sex
position and i'll say guys like
by all means do any sex position that
you want but make sure no one's forcing
you into doing things you don't want to
do that sort of thing and i i do
actually get dms a lot that people are
like
i didn't realize that this was happening
to me until i heard you speak about it
so then i made a patreon which is i'm
sure you guys have heard of it it's like
a subscription site they don't um allow
explicit content such as what only fans
does but i started the patreon i just
did a few like hd shoots every month um
and i think it was 25
and people could it was like fully
clothed stuff it'd just be me and like
some like denim shorts and a nice top
that sort of thing and that's where i
started the whole
you know i'm gonna take back control of
my life and that's when i realized like
i'm 18 i can now do what i want
and then so when she started the patreon
does that your content start to change
to become a bit more sexy content yeah
so
i did the original content which is me
and like you know the denim shorts that
kind of thing then i started probably
three four months in
i started doing like some bikini stuff
then i started doing more like lingerie
stuff and then i remember this one time
i think it was in 2020
i posted a photo and i was like oh my
god that's like
different to what i used to do and then
that's when i realized that my content
was getting like more sexual but i
didn't mind it like at all and i really
enjoyed it and then when i was
i think 21
i made the only fans
i went all out i got my paid
subscription
i think it was 15
and i put it on twitter and everyone was
like oh my god like lauren has on only
fans because that was when like lockdown
was when only fans got really big so i
think it's been around since maybe 2016.
but yeah lockdown was when everyone was
excited about it
so when someone subscribes to your page
they'll see photos of you and then what
else can they do can they message you
how else does it work yep so there's a
home page which you'll subscribe you'll
make your account um
you can subscribe to like a free page
which a lot of people have or there's a
paid page
um and then yeah they have the message
option where people could for example be
like uh i'll send you a hundred dollars
if you can send me this that kind of
thing
so how many messages are you receiving
or sending a day i probably spend over
eight hours to 10 hours a day replying
to people
yeah i lose sleep over it but there's so
much that goes on behind the scenes it's
unreal like even the production of
content like i have one person who
shoots it then i have someone who
organizes it all and then i'll have
someone who reviews all the photos and
then i also have three people who are at
a shoot setting everything up like it's
the stuff that does actually go on
behind the scenes it is crazy but it's
the it's the replying to messages that
takes up the most time
eight to ten hours a day talking on only
fans two fans and i imagine a lot of
those messages are probably quite sexual
in nature yeah some of them
does that not does that have an impact
on your
own day-to-day life and your own like
dating life because it's always talking
about sex
that's the thing and i was actually
talking to someone about this recently
and i think some people really fail to
understand that
because my job is thinking talking the
whole thing is sex based
sometimes i'm less interested in
actual like romantic sexual
relationships because of that and
personally i've never like i've always
been a very sexual person i'm not
someone who goes around and sleeps with
loads of people like i have a very low
body count and
it's i found it very hard to like trust
sleeping with people because
i mean i know guys as well
myself in like my personal life who've
been like oh yeah like this bird and i
filmed her and stuff like i hate stuff
like that and i find it really hard to
trust that people aren't gonna like film
or just anything like
it really creeps me out but um
yeah no i'm definitely less interested
in romantic sexual relationships because
i'm thinking about sex like 20 hours a
day it's just always like even now we're
talking about sex you know like it's
just always sex sex sex and if it's not
sex it's just like
looking at pics or wherever it's just
always
i'm always switched on to sex mode yeah
have you had people say negative things
to you about starting an only fan and
starting this kind of content so
some people were kind of like oh i don't
know why she's doing that you know like
people were like oh she's a prostitute
which i mean i'm i'm definitely not
having sex with people for money put it
that way that is very very
very not what i do
but for me
it's no different than like the same the
same girls who said stuff about me from
my school when i started the only fans
are the same girls a few years ago who
are just sending nudes to guys for free
so i'm just like
i mean make it make sense like
you know it's something i enjoy i have a
passion for it
i'm very very interested in the entire
world of sex and those kind of emotions
and
for me it started as modeling and i do
the more like hd
glamour side of it like i put i put a
lot of work into what goes out there and
even for example even if it's
valentine's day
i'll have like an entire sheet planned
just for that and the stuff that goes on
behind the scenes like i really value it
as more than just
oh i'm just taking my clothes off but um
yeah people reacted
kind of they just reacted like i was
i'm gonna ask you probably the question
you asked the most about only fans which
is how much money are you actually able
to make on only fans
um
oh god the amount right now honestly is
endless um
i mean
did you guys see the bad baby thing she
made 52 million in in a year i i make a
hell of a lot of money i've never
revealed like my full like
i get this much a month um but i've had
days where i've made over six figures in
a day so it's i mean it's not obviously
every day but i have had days where it's
like
if something specific happens and i get
extra promotion like i have had that
which to me is insane like so insane i
get a lot of girls hating on me saying
like oh
if i made an only fans i would make
nowhere near as much but you can it's
possible anyone can and i know even
males who
make millions a month on only fans like
it's so crazy it's crazy so because you
work with a lot of other youtubers
people like the sidemen people like that
there how do you find collaborating with
other youtubers in the uk youtube scene
um
one thing i always get asked is
oh like is ksi the same in real life
that's one thing everyone is the exact
same and i think people think we put on
this like
this crazy
act and we're we're so different on
camera but we're exactly the same how i
sit and act on camera is how i am in
real life and that's the same for every
person i've met and collaborating with
other youtubers such as the sidemen or
callux and stuff like that
i when i first collaborated with the
cyber i think it was
two years ago i think maybe just over
two years ago two and a half years ago
maybe that's simon tinder yeah deciding
tinder and that for me
i was like oh my god like this is crazy
but now it's like
they're my everyday friends it's weird
how things change for me because i'm one
of the the one of the girls in the
youtube industry who does have like a
very sexual side to me and i'm very open
people love seeing me collab with other
male youtubers because
they assume the maddest things and the
comments are always like we all know
what happened after this and it's so
crazy to me but you know people love
seeing me with other males just because
i'm a sexual person but i mean it works
for me it works for them so
fair enough i put you on the spot then
which side man do you enjoy
collaborating with the most
okay um
oh
uh when we're on set i'd say
the most fun person is probably jj he's
either sleeping or really wide awake and
funny but i think i spend the most time
with jj so pro probably jj
that guy is a workaholic and every time
i'm sitting there like i work a huge
amount of time
and i love i like i really enjoy what i
do but if i'm having a bad day where i'm
like
oh i don't want to get out of bed today
which does happen every other month i'll
sit there and i'll be like and i guess i
would get up could get out of bed so
that i think that motivates me because
behind the scenes i know he's such a
workaholic that even if i have like a
few hours of not doing work i feel so
guilty so yeah he's probably someone i
look up to in the uk just because i mean
he's huge
obviously you're you're you're an online
presence you're
have you ever had anyone famous slide
into the dms
um i have yeah i've had some very famous
people sliding my dm yeah probably
footballers
boxers
i get a lot of rappers in my dms i do
want a dm from giancarlo but i haven't
had that yet so yeah jack if you're
watching this
i will
just say
do you always want to be making content
on only fans what's the kind of what do
you want in life so i've got a lot of
things coming up at the moment i've got
a project called peachy religion which
i'm working on which i can't reveal
right now but that's coming very soon
which i'm really excited for and that's
been in the works for about 18 months
and also i've got something else coming
which
where
it involves only fans but where i'm
an only fans model and i'm very
successful with it one thing i hate the
most is seeing girls in the industry
being taken advantage of and i don't
mean like physically i mean like
people literally just management
companies
will give them so many fake promises and
take sometimes 50 60 70 of their
earnings
and that's so crazy to me like
some of these girls because they
they've started with nothing they have
no followers and they want to be they
want to be
an influencer they want to be you know
social media famous they want to be that
kind of person
they give away so much to be able to do
that and i know some people will even
say you know i'm making a thousand a
month on only fans i want to get and
then these management companies will say
we can get that to a hundred thousand a
month but for the first two years you've
got to give us like 75 of your earnings
which is so crazy to me these management
companies they give the girls no moral
support there's no
mental health
there's no like resources for that
there's
they don't give them any help at all and
they don't even guide them properly so
one thing i want to do is i want to take
some time out of my day every day
working with girls who haven't had the
same opportunity that i've had they
haven't had the same team of people
behind them like 100 of the time
and they don't get the right advice and
i just want to give them advice and help
them make a good career in it and kind
of just take them under my wing and
almost like mentor them into becoming
successful with it and just telling them
the
how it is on a real basis because no one
ever says it how it is
you can never really be true friends
after something like that i just don't
think it can ever ever happen maybe if
you
fought and it was a draw
maybe you could still be friends but
the idea of being friends with someone
that
has a beating you it's a hard thing for
your head to compute